chadwick boseman's widow
taylor simone ledward is asking a judge
to make her an administrator of his
estate
this because chadwick died without a
will according to court documents
obtained by e.t
ledward filed the probate case on
thursday the documents also show the
estimated value of chadwick's estate to
be just over
938 000 the only other family members
listed in the docs are the actors
parents
leroy and carolyn the black panther star
passed away in august after battling
colon cancer
he was 43 years old he had quietly
married taylor before his death
it's a beautiful thing and while the
pair kept their romance extremely
private he publicly thanked her at the
2019 naacp awards
i simone you're with me every day
i have to acknowledge you right now love
you
some fans also now think that that
speech may have hinted at his health
struggles
you know they say black people always
thank god when they win and i'm not
going to let you down
they thank you god for uh
not not just winning um
thank you god for the trials and
tribulations that you allow us to go
through
so that we can we can appreciate these
moments we can appreciate the joy
that comes um from winning